this isn't keeping up with the
kardashians this is keeping up with the
kids
keeping up with the kardashians may be
over but i'm fully with penelope and
north here
for keeping up with the kids tune in
because you never know what's going to
happen
during the series finale of the family's
hit reality show on e
kim kardashian's daughter seven-year-old
north and kourtney kardashian's daughter
eight-year-old penelope
have a little fun making home videos of
their own
and seemingly have the next spin-off
series ready to go hello
hi camera versus camera come here oh no
this
isn't keeping up with the kardashians
this is keeping up with the kids
yeah so we're gonna go do that bye kids
okay too cute right i love it
and it seems like the kiddos picked up
some tv lingo over the years
growing up on camera don't worry
production's not over
penelope's like don't worry production
is not over and she's a camera
right now production's not over
guys she's eight i'm impressed
amazing and while north and penelope
were busy capturing memories on their
cameras
the famous fam was busy reliving some of
their best ones over the past
14 years i love that chris
courtney kim chloe kendall and kylie
played a round of charades
reenacting some iconic keeping up scenes
ready set go got this
yeah like that time kim performed with
the pussycat dolls circa 2009.
oh kim pussycat dolls well i don't know
about you guys but i'm feeling
really dirty tonight when kendall kylie
and chloe dressed up in disguises
and rode on a hollywood tour bus nose oh
when they dressed up and did the
prosthetic nose
block the theme down there to the right
california before you've never been to
california oh good
then there was kylie's lasik eye surgery
her eye laser lasik eye surgery
i am a lasik surgery survivor my name is
kylie jenner
and my personal favorite that time
kendall fell off her bike and laughed it
off like a boss
naturally it got pretty competitive
between the two teams
kendall kylie and chloe on one team kim
chris and courtney on the other
oh wow this is hard um mom mom okay
scott scott mom you're on the wrong team
oh my god that is naked in front of mom
scott what hurry up get a new one
and in the end team kim court and chris
won
it's always so much fun of course the
famous fam announced in september their
decision to end
keeping up with its 20th season at the
time the show's executive producer ryan
seacrest
told et the decision was a tough one for
them
at some point you're gonna say you know
we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it but have no
fear because the kardashian jenners will
be back on tv
in no time since they inked a major new
deal with hulu